agora você vai aprender como é que faz
para o marcão rapidamente arrumada e aí
galera que a gente pra todo mundo por 6
até chegar em casa na casa do bairro
carregando o celular eu toque de bola
sem querer eu sentei no acordo com ela
não sei lá que briga agora só na cara de
todo mundo pra carregar o celular na
casa de um carro que 5% na casa de outro
carrega 10% a jamila raja amigo que é do
final de ano chegou mais uma vez o final
do ano é uma época maravilhosa e pede
que eu fico mais feliz assim época que
fora o amor no meu coração não eu vou
botar matizar período de fim de ano tá
ligado assim a começar por aqueles
carros de som fica passando na rua
fazendo aquelas propagandas chata de
natal olha eu ia sobrar oferta você que
não comprou seu presente de natal para
dar o seu amigo aí só que a minha
situação de capivara carros você como o
seu carro a partir de 19 mil reais pra
dar de presente passou família e os seus
amigos por vingança me dão nem aquele
papelzinho direito se mudou muito e
holanda e roubar um carro por aí o
negócio é um abuso é carro de som ea
loja começa a botar a decoração de natal
com o papai noel na porta sim estava
estão felizes então vim para pegar
dinheiro que o natal em dezembro em
abril a loja está montando papai noel na
porta em dia também acontece das duas
uma ou você vai pra casa de um parente
ou parente seu recurso o caso aí amanhã
a gente começa a pegar o uso manda
retirar malpartida gente olha você
arrume seu quarto hoje que sua tia vai
pra cá hoje wilting agora não entendo
uma coisa assim a dia vem para aqui pra
casa hoje ela vai fazer porque no meu
quarto nem o atendeu chamado fez pra mim
para pagar as contas beleza que manda em
casa mas quase não fez pra mim é o fator
quadra fez pra mim para minha tia fez
pra mim foi dada a vontade de falar
assim mas no quarto a senhora que já
está de bom tamanho se ela perguntar por
que o quarto bagunçado fala meu lado
sabe toda aí todo porém meus desde já
não são muito certinho e sim se eu falar
algo que minha mãe a iacc bagunça toda a
mágoa mas aguarda ainda aguentava o pior
é quando ela manda a gente acordar cedo
nas férias
olha pergaminhos e acorde cedo viu a mãe
da gente tem uma noiva com esse negócio
de acordar cedo eu também não entendo
que esse negócio que há muita gente que
quer que a gente fique acordado sempre
vai fazer nada tira o final do ano
espera se ela quer porque quer ver a
gente acordar a chama de vagabunda chão
a gente preguiçoso alguém explica a mãe
da gente que a questão não é o sempre
isso a questão é se eu não vou fazer
nada eu não vejo o porquê ele não ficar
acordado que a minha presença como não
fazer muita diferença tenha ficado me
defendendo sempre tem também aquela tia
que contará também com aqueles tirar
gente que perde mais a itf engraçadão
não sabe que este quer fazer a perda do
parceiro no final de ano o equipamento
eu vejo um pavilhão j que ele tinha ido
antes engraçado e fácil ficar com meu
filho que não é pavê não também é que
eles brinquem passar a virada do ano na
casa da gente acorda do que falar aquela
piadinha nosso
parece que a última vez que eu escolher
os meus deles foi no ano passado aí vai
de boa não é pra mim o único sinal de
boa não tem graça para adiantar nem
sempre é aquele jingle da globo hoje é
um novo tempo de um honda abreu catar
esgotado problema na família hoje é um
novo tempo de um novo ou no cara para
recuperação na escola não sabe se vai
passar hoje é o nono tempo de um novo um
time dívida já em pontes e se dá hoje
no tempo de um ano um globo ainda não
entendeu que a pessoa tá pontifício da
letra universo na casa cantando ele se
mata e essa propaganda muita facilidade
que ela falasse em todos os nossos
sonhos serão verdade paulo quando era
pequena para lembrar que meu sonho é a
bíblia de ferro vocês soubessem de a do
arco e flecha que eu ganhei ou 26 ago
tanto no natal na minha vida é chover em
todo lugar do bicho eu vou contar uma
história pra você de um fim de ano e
meio que não foi muito bom né eu lembro
que no ano retrasado eu fiquei de
recuperação e matemático e todos os dias
eu acordava incansavelmente e
impreterivelmente às 6 horas da manhã
para pegar o ônibus e hoje eu conto pra
vocês aqui agora com a emoção dos meus
olhos que eu nunca conseguia chegar na
hora certa pra pegar esse ônibus quando
eu chegar a última pessoa já tava
entrando do uno quando eu entrar nesse
ônibus
eu sempre dava azar de ficar tarde unir
a minha é diferente não é normal um
homem bonito um amigo como qualquer um
único defeito que ela tinha era todo dia
colocar um litro de crer no cabelo dela
e senhores aquele ônibus ele sempre
estava lotado apesar de ser recuperação
é como dizer que nos meus amigos não
eram aqueles mais inteligentes né
e eu em pé tá naquela menina olha
naquele cremes corrente para pessoa
passa tanto creme no cabelo dela de um
cabelo dela vêm até aqui cremes corre
até aqui e colocar uma música no meu
ouvido não conseguia me concentrar na
letra da música fica naquela por aqueles
pingo de creio que deve ser assim até
cenas que escorre pingando eu ia pra
aquela sala de reforço não conseguia me
concentrar mesmo depois todos tirar
aquele onde o professor falava aqui a
equação ela vem falando pra você que eu
conseguia escutar ela o pinho de treinar
aqui vem descendo até o tenho de crescer
daqui com a velocidade do pico de treino
consegui me concentrar a gente é a vez
de pegar tanto creme no cabelo e canino
que impeçam que aquele onde das duas
ruas mulher morreu afogada
e foi assim que meu filho
o ano terminou naquele a maldição do
creme maldito do satanás
até hoje quando vou ao supermercado sem
aproveitar suas carteiras de crédito mas
há uma crise a gerente eo segurança me
segurar eu começar a querer tocar fogo
todos os cremaram tempo mais o fim de
ano seja bom ele vai receber um presente
muito ganhei a flecha maioria que o
brinquedo porque ele prevê que o 5 ano
porque na hora que eu queria mas gostei
vou aproveitar aqui eu fiquei em
recuperação tem uma maldição do crei
mais apesar do espírito de 3 malditos de
satanás
eu que tem mais tempo com meus amigos ou
curtir mais
e eu acho que é legal não não não não
não acredito não eu não acredito que ia
sair daqui sem clicar em gostei do vídeo
é não não não não não não não um destino
não disse não vai ter que gostei pra
ajudar nós não gostei pra nós para o fim
de ano é bom também presente falar em
presente é de fim de ano dia 29 deste
mês a que de 29 depois da manhã agora ou
amanhã se hoje foi de 28 ou e se eu já
fui dia 29 eu já podia 29 esportivo
então pra falar para lá o black friday
sexta feira que tem no mundo todo e
também aqui no brasil em que os preços
das lojas estarem muito sábio e então
nós me ajuda a comprar coisas comprar um
microfone dá uma luz uma coisa assim tal
que a canon é o homem que faz o carro de
som desgraça passa na quinta feira então
sexta feira dia 29 na canoa 8 vai ver
desconto do [ __ ] tem produtor que vai
conseguir até 80 oitenta por cento de
desconto e citou comprar pelo linkin
park na descrição do vídeo tu vai
queimar 10% de desconto pode ter 90% que
desculpa pra você não está entendendo eu
vou te explicar que se tu for comprar um
produto de r$100 tu pode conseguir por
10 pontos em 10 10 de [ __ ] fé e dez
reais
mas isso se você comprar pelo link tac a
descrição do vídeo que você vai ter mais
10% de desconto aí também varia de
produto a adotarem produto que dá 50%
têm pavor que dá a 67 depende muito
distribuído então você não esquece dia
29 é que é sexta feira você vai lá no
rio ceira compra lá parado
a e usa um bom lá com o meu nome pra
você poderoso para você poder ter 10% de
desconto a mais se hoje foi dia 29 pode
negar porque só hoje se discutam entre
as redes sociais todos é só você me
seguir você nunca vai entender o vídeo e
não se esquece de explicar se inscrever
e é nóis tá lennonyc